Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ich heiße Fukunbaran und bin auf dieser Station als Diensthabender arztätig.
Ich würde gerne mit dieser Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Gottschalk.
Petra Gottschalk.
Petra ist eine Frau.
Ja.
Und Frau Gottschalk, können Sie Ihre Nachname langsam bestabieren?
Ja. Gottschalk schreibt sich G-O-T-T-S-C-H-A-L-K.
Gottschalk.
Okay. Frau Gottschalk, wie alt sind Sie?
56.
Wann wurden Sie gebogen?
Am 4. April 1967.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
61 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Und haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, Frau Dr. Schmidt.
Und Frau Gottschalk, was hat Sie zu uns geführt?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 4 Stunden ziemlich stark Schmerzen im Brustkorb.
Mehr hinten, so am unteren Schulterblatt, im unteren Schulterblatt Bereich.
Also mehr hinten, am unteren Teil des Schulterblattes.
Also rücken schmerzen, oder?
Ja, aber mehr so Brustkorb.
Und haben Sie Engel gefühlt bemerkt?
Ja, also der Schmerz wird schlimmer, wenn ich einatme.
Oder wenn ich auch mal husten muss.
Und auch wenn ich mich umdrehe, so im Sessel, so.
Das kann ich nicht.
Drehen tut weh, tief einatmen tut weh, husten tut weh.
Sie haben diese Schmerzen seit 4 Stunden.
Seit 4 Stunden, ja.
Und die Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Ja, die geht so ein bisschen nach vorne.
Also nach vorne, links in die Brust rein, fast bis zum Brustbein.
Und ich glaube, diese Schmerzen hat plötzlich begonnen, oder?
Ja.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala, wenn eins bis zehn, eins vom bis zehn, wenn eins leichte und zehn unerträgliche Schmerzen sind?
Ich würde sagen, wenn ich gar nicht mich bewege und nicht tief atme, sind Sie bei 5 bis 6.
Aber wenn ich mich dann, wenn ich tief atme oder huste, dann können Sie bis 8 sein.
Okay. Können Sie nun diese Schmerzen ertragen oder?
Ja, um die geht es.
Okay, klar.
Und wie verhalten Sie die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit?
Schlimm geworden oder ein bisschen besser geworden?
Nee, sind eher vielleicht sogar etwas schlimmer geworden.
Und können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben, also pochende, zihende oder brennende Schmerzen, was können Sie sagen?
Ja, sind mehr so stechend.
Okay, und haben Sie Husten?
Normalerweise etwas, weil ich auch rauche.
Aber jetzt tut es beim Husten auch schon weh, wenn ich husten muss.
Und kommt raus Schleim, wenn Sie Husten?
Schleim? Nein, Schleim kommt nicht raus.
Das habe ich nur ganz manchmal im Jahr, im Winter hatte ich mal eine schwere Bronchitis, aber jetzt habe ich mehr so einen Reiz Husten.
Okay. Und haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Und Schutelfrost, oder ist Ihnen übel?
Nein.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas hümsüfrigen? Haben Sie es irgendwelche oder irgendetwas bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe mir überlegt, woher das vielleicht kommen kann.
Ich habe davor, habe ich einen schweren Blumentopf gehoben und auf eine Bank gestellt.
Eventuell kann es damit zu tun, aber ich musste mich so bücken und drehen.
Und das war vom Gefühl her nicht so gut.
Vielleicht liegt es daran, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Und haben Sie Atemnutz bemerkt, oder?
Also, wie gesagt, ich traue mich gar nicht so tief einzuatmen, weil sich dann der Schmerz wird stärker.
Deswegen, ja, wenn ich jetzt die Treppe steigen würde, dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich etwas Atemnot.
Das habe ich mir gar nicht gemacht.
Okay, Frau Gottschalk, ich werde diese Gespräche unterbrechen.
Und ich möchte einen EKG verschreiben lassen.
Während der EKG-Verschreibung werden wir diese Gespräche weitermachen.
Ja.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Habt ihr kleine Schlafprobleme?
Das ist eigentlich gut, ich kann gut schlafen.
Und schwitzen Sie in der Nacht?
Und schwitzen Sie nun?
Nein.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder ungewollt abgenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay.
Und waren Sie umrächtig wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Nein.
Und leiden Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, was meinen Sie jetzt an Vorerkrankungen?
Du als Beispiel?
Superkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Ich habe eine, seit 25 Jahren habe ich eine Schildrösen-Unterfunktion.
Das sei eine Autoimmun-Unzündung der Schildröse.
Und da nehme ich ein Medikament ein.
Ultirox 75 heißt das.
Nehm ich eine Tablette morgens.
Und Tirox 75?
Ultirox.
Und ich habe es total vergessen.
Gibt es etwas Auslöse für die Schmerzen?
Ja, eventuell habe ich gesagt, habe ich einen schweren Blumentopf angehoben.
Und das kann vielleicht dazu beigetragen haben, dass plötzlich dieser Schmerz da entstand.
Vielleicht denkt es damit, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie an andere Vorerkrankungen, außer Hypertroöse?
Ja, ich habe seit 20 Jahren ungefähr eine Milchzucker-Unverträglichkeit.
Aber damit komme ich gut zurecht.
Damit kann ich mich ganz gut orangschieren.
Was machen Sie dagegen? Tablette einnehmen?
Manchmal Tabletten und ich achte drauf auf Nahrungsmittel,
dass die Milchzuckerarm sind oder Milchzucker frei sind.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt oder operiert?
Das war, ja, ich hatte einen Leistenbruch.
Als Kind.
Links, da war ich vielleicht acht.
Und dann hatte ich einen, wenn ich mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt,
hatte ich den Unterarm gebrochen, die Speiche, links, die Speiche der Speichen tochen.
Und da wurde ich operiert mit einer Platte.
Und wann haben Sie diese Fahrradunfallgeschehen?
Da war ich, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt.
Und wie ist die Impfstattung? Sind Sie gegen Covid-Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich war jetzt bei meinem Hausarzt, der das alles überprüft und sagt,
meine Impfungen sind im Augenblick gut und ausreichend.
Ich habe dann noch, also eine Operation hatte ich noch vor fünf Jahren,
wurde mir die Gallenblase entfernt, weil ich Steine hatte
die auch Beschwerden machten.
Ja, ich verstehe ganz genau.
Und waren Sie in anderen Land oder im Ausland?
Ich war vor drei Monaten mal für eine Woche in England.
Aber sonst habe ich keine großen Reisen gemacht, keine Fernreisen.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie außer die Erdtrucks- und Laktase-Tablete irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Tableten ein.
Okay. Sie haben Laktose, Milch-Unfertiglichkeiten.
Ja.
Sonst haben Sie Allergien oder die andere Unfertiglichkeiten?
Nein, nein, nicht bekannt.
Okay. Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie rauchen Sie.
Und was rauchen Sie?
Rauchen Sie seit 30 Jahren, Rauch. Ich zöge eine Schachtel am Tag.
Zigaretten, oder?
Zigaretten. Nur während der Schwangerschaften habe ich damit aufgehört.
Ja, wenn Sie mit Rauchen wieder aufhören möchten,
dann haben wir hier einen Spezialisten, die Ihnen helfen können.
Wenn Sie möchten, ich kann mit Ihnen, mit Ihnen, ja, eine Termin bereinbaren.
Okay, danke.
Und Frau Gottschalk, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber unregelmäßig.
Ich trinke mal vielleicht ein Glas Bier, aber das ist vielleicht einmal die Woche,
zweimal die Woche.
Und ich muss eine unangenehme Frage stellen, aber diese Frage gehört zu einem
vollständigen Aufnahmegespräch.
Deswegen, bitte, nehmen Sie die nicht persönlich.
Also haben Sie einmal Drogen probiert oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, habe ich noch nie.
Sehr gut.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich mache zweimal in der Woche, gehe ich ins Fitnessstudio
und einmal in der Woche mache ich Yoga.
Zweimal Fitnessstudio, nein, eine Woche.
Und Yoga.
Sehr gut.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienstand, Frau Gottschalk, sind Sie verheiratet?
Verheiratet, habe zwei Kinder, 27 und 25 Jahre alt.
Wir sind gesund.
Und wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie, oder?
Nur noch mit dem Mann, die Kinder wohnen selbstständig, sind woanders.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Zahntechnikerin.
Und haben Sie viel Stress bei Arbeit?
Nein.
Die Arbeit macht mir Spaß, finde ich jetzt nicht sehr anstrengend.
Ich brauche keine Nachtdienste machen, keine Wochenenddienste.
Das ist eigentlich sehr angenehm.
Sehr gut.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch, Frau Gottschalk?
Der Vater ist mit 72 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben
und hatte mit 60 Krebs.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt auch vor einem Vierteljahr
eine Darmenspiegelung machen lassen.
Die war in Ordnung.
Und die Mutter ist 82 Jahre alt, die lebt.
Die hat etwas hohen Blutdruck und Alterszucker.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester, die ist 54 Jahre alt.
Die hat Asthma, ein bisschen allergisches Asthma
und hat auch bekannte Geilensteine.
Und Frau Gottschalk, haben Sie normalerweise Magenprobleme?
Also Aufstoßen, Sortbränen?
Nein.
Hatten Sie?
Nein, habe ich bisher keine Probleme mit gehabt.
Sehr gut.
Und Frau Gottschalk, wir sind am Ende dieses Aufnahmigeschiperech.
Ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen,
dann Ihnen ein Blut abnehmen.
Dann soll ich mit meinem Oberarzt über Ihren Fall sprechen.
Ich werde Sie jetzt rechtsseitig informieren.
Okay.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen oder hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich hoffe, dass meine Schmerzen bald nachlassen.
Ich hoffe auch.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen eine andere Frage?
Ich habe manche Dinge nicht ganz verstanden,
aber Blut, Tropfen, Blumentopf gehoben.
Was ist das? Ich weiß es nicht.
Blumentopf, Arjukaldermisch.
Ah.
Ja, ich habe einen Blumentopf angehoben.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Linker Seite oder rechte Seite?
Linker Seite, unter dem Schulterblatt.
Unten, unter.
Mehr hinten.
Entweder gangen Sie, aber beim tiefen Atmen strahlen Sie bis vorne hin.
Ja.
Sie werden einatmen, ich sage vorne.
Einatmen, ja, und husten.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Beinschmerzen?
Beinschmerzen? Nein.
Sind Ihnen Taubheitskrippen oder Lehmung erscheinen und gern bekannt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, noch nie gehabt.
Zum Beispiel linken Arm, Bewegung.
Ich probiere nicht, das geht ganz.
Aber wenn ich den Arm jetzt so hochhebe, dann spüre ich auch unten in der Schulter,
hinten im Schulterblatt, aber nicht hier oben in der Schulter,
sondern tiefer hier.
Dann tut das etwas wehwählig, so hochhebe.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt und der Patient hat deutlich schreiben.
Können wir als als geschebte Anfang?
Nur ein Minutes kann ich denken.
Okay.
Patientin würde ich noch ergänzen.
Mein Stuhlgang ist regelmäßig.
Ja.
Ich muss noch Wasser lassen.
Ist in Ordnung.
Einmal in der Nacht muss ich Wasser lassen.
Herr Rasen, ich bin stolz.
Momentan.
Nein.
Keine Frage.
Diese Fragen, was haben wir?
Zianose.
Diagnose?
Ja, Zianose.
Zianose.
Was haben wir?
Blaue Lippen oder blaue Lippen, blaue oder häufiger Finger?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Welche Fragen?
Haben Sie blaue Lippen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine blaue Lippen.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich glaube, ich kann das machen.
Bitte schön.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt.
Ein Moment.
Diese ähnliche Beschwerden haben Sie gehalten?
Nein, diese Beschwerden habe ich so noch nie gehabt.
Zum Beispiel Rückenprobleme.
Ich hatte schon mal vor Jahren Rückenbeschwerden.
Das war aber mehr ein Ischias.
Ja, Ischias.
Aber das sind jetzt andere Beschwerden.
Danke schön.
Nur um Fragen.
Bekommen Sie nun Regelblutung oder Monatsblutung?
Nein, die sind unregelmäßig geworden in den letzten Jahren.
Ich bin regelmäßig in grün-ökologischer Kontrolle,
aber das ist nicht mehr regelmäßig.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin, um Ihnen vorzustellen.
Darf ich anfangen?
Ja.
Frau Petra Gottschalk ist 56 Jahre alt.
Sie hat sich heute bei uns wegen seit 4 Stunden aufgetreten.
Sie hat sich vorhin über die ganze Zeit begonnen,
weil sie sich mit dem Schuhschaum auf den Schuhschaum und auf den Schuhschaum
als Schuhschaum gelassen.
Sie hat sich über die Zeit geholfen.
und Plätsch-Begonnen hatten Plätsch-Begonnen.
Zusätzlich teilt sie mit das die Schmerzen 5 bis 6 Konzene auf die Schmerzskalazie.
Und wenn sie höchsten 9 Konzene auf der Schmerzskalazie,
es gäbe nach einem Blumentopf zu heben,
da die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Die Patientin sieht einen Zusammenhang mit der Entstehung des Schmerzes
mit dem Heben eines Blumentopfes.
Ja.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen sind beim Treppensteigen auch schlimmer geworden.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Schütter, Frost, Übelkeit,
ummächtig, Südenkopf, Schweißausbrüche wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unauffällig bis auf eine Necturie
und unregelmäßige Monatsblutzung seit einem Jahr.
Die Frau Petra Gottschak leide an Vorerkrankungen, die Folgenden an.
Eine Hypothriose seit 25 Jahren,
sie sagte Autoimmun-Charakterische.
Aber ich weiß es nicht ganz genau.
Ich kann diese Probleme zum Dr. Schmidt, also ihre Hausarzt fragen.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde eine Kolesistiktomie durchgeführt.
Mit acht Jahren wurde sie wegen eines Leisten herrni operiert
und mit zehn Jahren wegen eines Fahrradunfalles an links schpaichel operiert.
Die Linke ist auf der linken Seite und auf der linken Seite.
Mit Plattenostiösyntese.
Sie schpaichelt.
Hat die Speiche gesagt oder alle?
Ja, sie schpaichelt.
Mit Plattenbehandelt wurde die Statue verständig.
Die Reise am Neyse ergab vor vier Monaten.
Eine Reise.
Und in Besuch auf Medikation,
eine Ertrogsin 75 mg, einmal täglich.
Und Laktase tablette, wenn sie Milchprodukte versehren.
wegen einer Laktose unverträglich.
Ja, Unverzöglichkeiten. Sie haben eine Laktoseintoleranz.
Vor 20 Jahren wurde diese Diagnose festgestellt.
Und Bragocak rauche Einschachtelsigaretten.
Täglich seit 30 Jahren, also 20 Peggiers
und trinke ein Mal in der Woche.
Und sie hatten keine Drogenkontakte.
Gibt es Risikofaktoren in der Familie?
Ja, Vater ist an Myokardinfarktus gestorben.
Und hat Vater eine Vorerkrankung?
Und mit 60 Jahren.
Sie ist 82 Jahre alt.
Sie ist Arteriehipatronie und die Abizemilitistip 2.
Haben Sie bei der Patientin die Vitalparameter überprüft?
Oder die EKG veranlasst?
Ja, ich habe die Aufnahmegespräch unterbrochen.
Dann habe ich eine EKG verschrieben lassen.
Haben Sie auch schon den Blutdruck mit?
SPO 2?
Nein, aber ich soll diese Untersuchung gerne noch machen.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die Anamnistische Nangabe, die Leute, die nicht mehr mit der Anamnistik sind.
Aber als Differenzialdiagnose kommen die Folgen in Betracht.
Myokardinfarktus, Osteoporose und Wandscheibenvorfall.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiegnose?
Der atemabhängige Schmerz, könnte das auch mehr der Pleurat zu tun haben?
Ja, das kann sein. Pynomotorax vielleicht.
Aber sie hat keine Atemnot, aber trockenen Wurst.
Die Atemnot hat angegeben, dass sie nicht gut tief einatmen kann.
Und dass der Schmerz sich verstärkt beim Einatmen und beim Bewegen.
Der Schmerz begann nicht in der Brust, sondern der Schmerz begann Dorsal.
Unter dem Schulterblatt mit Ausstrahlung nach vorne in die Brust.
Also nicht nach hinten strahlen, sondern der Beginn war hinten.
Und dann einstrahlen.
Weil Sie das zuerst so gesagt haben.
Das begann in der Brust und strahlte nach hinten.
Es ist genau andersherum.
Ich habe gedacht, und auch die Sektion aber.
Es kann einen Zusammenhang durchaus geben mit dem Heben einer schweren Last.
Mit dem Blumentkübel, mit dem Blumentopf.
Das ist etwas, was in der Praxis sehr oft vorkommt.
Was ich sehr oft erlebt habe.
Die Patienten kommen und bieten ein Bild,
dass man erst mal denkt, Torachschmerz links mit eventuell Herz.
Sie haben eine EKG veranlasst.
Das war sehr gut.
Wichtig ist noch, sichert den Blutdruck leicht zu messen.
Und vielleicht SBO2 zu messen.
Beruhigt den Patienten und beruhigt auch den Arzt.
Ich würde die Diagnose stellen.
Akutes Brustwirbelsäulen-Syndrom mit Blockierung der Rippe.
Das sieht man in der Klinik nicht oft, aber in der Praxis sehr oft.
Die Patienten haben diese Schmerzen, die beginnen hinten.
Beim Atmen und Bewegen strahlen die Schmerzen nach vorne aus.
Da muss man eben differenzial diagnostisch die gravierenden Erkrankungen
natürlich ausschließen, wie Myokratinfarkt, eine Lungenproblematik.
Es kann eine Pluritis sein.
Es kann natürlich auch eine Osteoporose sein.
Aber würde ich jetzt erst mal vielleicht nicht so primär dran denken.
Natürlich die vital bedrohlichen Sachen zuerst ausschließen.
Das haben Sie mit dem EKG schon mal gut gemacht.
Vielleicht kann man einen Troponintest auch noch gleich machen,
um da vielleicht schon mal etwas sicherheit zu haben.
Ich vorwärsche ganz gerne.
Aber es ist sehr oft so in der Praxis,
dass die Patienten wegen dieser Schmerzen kommen,
beginnen hinten relativ akut.
Manchmal hilft es sogar, wenn man das kann.
Man macht vorhin EKG, man macht Blutest.
Wenn man dann sagt, das ist in Ordnung,
dann kann man versuchen, eine vorsichtige Mobilisation
der Wirbelsäule zu machen.
Das kann in Orthopäde machen, aber das kann auch im Hausarzt machen.
Also Physiotherapeut mobilisieren.
Oft kann man diese Blockierung lösen.
Und dann sind die Patienten sehr schnell beschwerdefrei.
Aber erst müssen die ernsten Erkrankungen ausgeschlossen werden.
Die Kardiale, weil ich sehe, der Kardiologe, der Moderator,
ist sehr auf das Kardiale bedacht, was ich auch verstehe.
Kurz in Kritik.
Denken Sie noch mal daran, dass Sie versuchen,
das in die medizinischen Fachausdrücke zu übersetzen.
Der Vater erkrankte an Damenkrebs, das ist richtig.
Aber das gehört beim Oberarzt,
müssen Sie schon sagen, an Kolonkazinomen.
Wirklich.
Oder sagen ein akuter, linksdorsaler Torachschmerz,
kann man vielleicht sagen, in Höhe der Stapulaspitze,
so als Lokalisation, mit Ausstrahlung bis Sternal,
links beim Inspiration, beziehungsweise bei Laggeänderung.
Bei der Inguinalherne auch sagen, herneotomie, als Begriff, herneotomie.
Die OP?
Wie bitte?
Inguinalherneotomie.
Herneotomie.
Der leistende.
Laktose-Inpolaranz oder Laktose-Unverträglichkeit,
haben Sie gebracht.
Bei der Schildrüse würde ich sagen,
wahrscheinlich eine Hashimoto-Tyrioditis
oder Autoimmuntyrioditis,
das sind Begriffe, glaube ich,
die jetzt in der Prüfung gerne gesehen werden,
die nicht gewünscht werden.
Oder es besteht ein Nikotin-Abusus über 30 Packageiers,
das haben Sie dann so ein bisschen nachgereicht, das war gut.
Aber ansonsten war ich zufrieden von der Gistik her,
achten Sie drauf, wenn Sie mit dem Oberarzt sprechen,
dass Sie beim Sprechen nicht zu oft die Hand vor den Mund nehmen.
Ich glaube, in der Endes-Dicht-Welke.
Ja, das ist eine Stressreaktion.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass Sie das möglichst nicht tun.
Ja, gut, aber dafür machen wir ja dieses Training.
Aber ich möchte auch noch mal daran denken,
wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, auch mit dem Blumentopf,
mit dem Blumentkübel, lieber noch einmal fragen.
Ich habe das nicht richtig verstanden,
können Sie mir das noch einmal erklären?
Das ist, glaube ich, wichtig, weil Sie müssen dann eventuell
dem Oberarzt schildern, was eine auslösende Ursache sein kann
für diese Beschwerden.
Ich habe bewusst jetzt keinen Myokatin-Fakt genommen,
sondern das ist vermeintlich einfacher,
weil es auch sehr häufig vorkommt.
Aber man muss eben die Differenzialdiagnostik machen,
um vital bedrohliche Sachen natürlich auszuschließen.
Gut, das ist ganz schön.